okay
now practically speaking i may get into
your creative process here but do you
have a google doc with bullet points of
all the different types of
puzzle elements like let's say this one
was shape delineation then another one
with apple tree is something like visual
environmental clue
and then another one maybe audio
discernment with the birds chirping so
then do you have spoilers everybody
so then do you have massive spoilers are
happening
so do you have
a google doc of a or whatever doc of a
bullet point of these are the types of
puzzle elements now as i progress
through the story i would like to
include more and more of these
simultaneously or does that happen
unconsciously or do you not even care if
that happens
it's different depending on where
you are building the thing right in the
beginning i'm just like i want to find
enough ideas that even
are interesting at all right
um
and then
um like putting things in in a
spreadsheet or something is not a very
um
i mean it helps you list them and
remember what they are but the thing is
in games um
it's much better to just build a very
early version of the game and so that's
what i did like from the very i would
say week
probably week two or three of
development of the six and a half year
project i had some version of the game
where you could walk around and it was
really ugly
not much to look at
not much there but then if i made new
puzzles i could just put them there i
could program them first of all and then
put them there
by programming them you see how they
actually behave and whether their ideas
in there that you didn't think of
right whereas if it's just written in a
spreadsheet
it's not doing anything so you can't see
what it does right and so
that was the development process was
program new puzzles put them in the
world if i thought there was going to be
an area
where
where things might go i would just sort
of throw them on the map there and we
would put walls around it or something
and figure it out later um
actually i think it's still up
we have a
blog that we were doing that whole time
and it shows
you can see screenshots of what the game
looked like
in this state when it was like very
plain and ugly and just i believe i was
following it back then okay
yeah so
um that was really the primary method of
organization of the game really
you know probably the art team when they
were working on stuff had
probably some spreadsheets and stuff
about who
was going to work on what when
but
like that kind of thing but in terms of
the overall ideas of the game it was
just there in the game
and that's still true with with what we
work on now
why was it being non-verbal so important
to you
is this something like in filmmaking
there's that is don't tell but show is
it somehow more pure
or less pure if you are direct it's
probably related to the personality
aspect that i was telling you about
before where i don't like to talk about
some things like um
there are ways of
um
like speech is very linearizing right
like it goes whether it's spoken or
written it goes into a series of words
that then you listen to
and rebuild into something non-linear in
your head right and
that has a certain bandwidth to it of
what you how much you can do um it
actually could be quite high if you and
the person you're talking to have shared
assumptions about what things mean then
words call back to what those things
mean and help you build in l.a that's
that's why speech works right
um
but if you want to tell people about
something they don't already know
the bandwidth is actually pretty low
because you don't have
things to refer back to that are
uh that are big and rich informationally
so that's one thing but secondly i was
just really interested in this idea of
nonverbal communication and i wanted to
see what it could do in the medium of
games like is this something that games
can do
that they have a talent for right
relative to other media and i found
that it seemed to be so
um
because in in that game you know
if somebody gets toward the end of the
game and they're playing some puzzle
that they're stuck on it looks
complicated and you ask them what are
you trying to do tell me everything
about what you're trying to do if they
start trying to explain like well you
know i'm trying to
draw this line to go through this thing
and around this thing but not around
that thing because
with this thing over here and if they
try to explain to you everything that
that they're trying to do
um
it could take five minutes actually for
for the late game right
um
none of that was ever communicated
verbally ever
right and and so that's very interesting
is an interesting study of what could be
done that way now that said then also
um
the
one of the things that the game was
primarily concerned with was this moment
of epiphany that i was talking about
before when you understand something
that you didn't understand before right
like
in a puzzle game when you finally are
able to solve the puzzle hopefully it's
not because you did a bunch of brute
force things and then you finally
accidentally
did a thing and it said it's solved
that's not a very good puzzle right a
good puzzle is
you didn't see something now you see it
and
now it's very clear
and
adds something to your knowledge
and you can use that
to solve the puzzle and move on to the
next thing right
so
i felt like a game that's talking at you
all the time
was not very helpful because part of so
part of what i was trying to do was
okay at a very baseline just give people
a positive experience that has that kind
of moment of epiphany in it because
that's interesting and fun and
nice for people right one level above
that
um can we create these moments of
epiphany from different angles on
different topics all the time to give
people a sense of what all these topics
are either about space and light and
shadow
and sound or about
abstract notions like you know number
and group and all these things
um
can we build an appreciation for that
right
and then maybe one level above that is
can we exercise
people's feeling of epiphany in this
simple world
um
that shares
a lot with our world
even though it's a simpler version so
this game has lights colors and shadows
and
um sounds and our world has
these things in at least in human
experience so
so
if we can exercise the feeling of
epiphany
well and from enough different
directions in the field of this game can
that then
give people something that they can
carry out a little bit
right
that
maybe in the real world they have more
of a taste of what this
sudden understanding is is like
and maybe that can be interesting to
them in some way and i felt like a game
that was just talking to you all the
time
wasn't good for any of those layers
right
especially
i don't know like if somebody tells you
how to do something
you didn't really figure anything out
right
um
so
it's a weird thing too because one of
the decisions that i'm still not sure if
it was right
um
was how much talking to have in the game
at all because there are all these
recordings um from various people that
are
the game is like laced with them
but they're kind of all hidden in
corners and stuff you probably have to
be deliberately looking for them to find
most of them
um once you know there's a few that are
like placed out in the open just to give
people the idea that these things are
there
um
and maybe it would have been the right
thing to not have any of those and have
the game be completely silent um but
that didn't feel right to me either
um
even though it's more pure in a certain
way
and and the original idea of the game
was to have a very explicit storyline in
it with like a fiction and
things that were happening like a
narrator and all this stuff
and i cut that because that didn't feel
good either so
it's somewhere in this middle ground but
so it's weird because there is talking
in the game but all the talking in the
game is not at all about the puzzles
ever
right
and
you have to kind of ask the game for the
talking because otherwise you won't
get it
you